Montaigne disait que philosopher c'était
apprendre à mourir apprendre à mourir
c'est-à-dire apprendre à accepter l'idée
de la mort parce que pris dans son sens
littéral apprendre à mourir ça n'aurait
pas beaucoup de sens
nous n'apprenons pas à mourir nous
mourrons et nous n'avons pas le choix et
qu'on les appris ou pas le résultat sera
le même mais ce que vous le dire
Montaigne c'est que si on ne peut pas
empêcher que la mort nous emporte on
peut en revanche apprendre à accepter
cette idée et ainsi apaiser notre
angoisse notre angoisse de quitter ce
monde qui résume le tout de notre
existence
car qui existe-t-il à part notre